Hey everybody, this is our annual holiday episode. This is by far my favorite episode because it's a chance where we can chat with our listeners, people who we're ultimately serving and supporting. So really looking forward to this. We also have T-shirts to give away. And this year, we have the actual vendor, a new vendor for T-shirts. So it's going to be these really nice, high-quality vinyl print T-shirts, which I'm really, really excited about. I actually requested one of each design. And just because of shipping and, you know, I guess it being close to holidays and everything, I didn't get my t-shirts yet. So I'll make sure the t-shirts are good before I send it out to our winners. But several of our patrons will win t-shirts today, which is always a lot of fun.
大家好，这是我们一年一度的节日特辑。这是我最喜欢的一期节目，因为这是一个能与听众交流的机会，毕竟他们是我们最终服务和支持的对象。所以我非常期待。我们还有T恤要送给大家。今年我们换了一家新的T恤供应商。这些T恤将采用非常优质的乙烯基印花，我对此感到非常兴奋。我每种设计都申请了一件。只是因为物流，你知道，临近假期之类的原因，我还没收到我的T恤。所以我得先确认T恤质量没问题，再寄给我们的获奖者。今天会有几位赞助人赢得T恤，这总是很有趣。
It's always a nice show, I guess, to be able to give away free stuff. Yeah, totally. And I think, uh, it's also a,
能送出免费礼物总是一件很棒的事。是的，完全同意。而且我认为，呃，这也是一个，
you know, kind of good opportunity to answer questions. So we have a variety of different media here. We have questions coming in over email. We have questions coming in over the discord questions channel, which is the thing that I'm going to be checking most often. So if you're listening to this live, please post your questions over there. And we also have some questions coming in on Patreon, you know, DMs and all of that.
你知道，回答问题的好机会。我们这里有各种不同的媒体渠道。我们有通过电子邮件发来的问题，还有通过Discord问题频道发来的问题，这是我最常查看的地方。所以如果你正在收听直播，请把你的问题发到那里。我们还有一些通过Patreon私信等渠道发来的问题。
So really fun stuff. And we'll just kick it off with the first name in the list. As we always do, I'm not going to read out the full person's name i just don't know people have different um um you know tastes as far as privacy and everything yeah so so let's say paul s if if you're a patron uh and your last name starts with an s and your first name is paul you it's very very likely that you want a free t-shirt. So congratulations, Paul. And yeah, another nice thing about this vendor is they actually have a whole infrastructure in place for giveaways. And so it's much easier for people. People used to have to like play email tag with me to give me their address and everything. But I think we've got a new system
真的很有趣。我们先从名单上的第一个名字开始。像往常一样，我不会读出全名，因为我不知道大家对隐私之类的看法。所以，我们就叫他Paul S吧。如果你是赞助人，姓氏以S开头，名字叫Paul，那你很有可能赢得一件免费T恤。恭喜你，Paul。另外，这家供应商还有一个很棒的地方，他们有一整套用于赠品的系统。这对大家来说容易多了。以前人们还得跟我玩“电子邮件捉迷藏”来提供地址什么的。但我认为我们现在有了一个新系统，
in place now where people will be able to just enter their address and get an order, a t-shirt, and the expenses have already been paid for you. So it's just like buying a t-shirt, except you don't have to. So you don't have to keep sending me your zip code and everything. So congratulations, Paul, on your t-shirt. Really exciting. That is very awesome. You want me to take it away with our first question? Yeah, let's do it. All right.
大家可以直接输入地址并下单领取T恤，费用已经预付了。就像买T恤一样，只是你不需要自己掏钱。所以你不需要一直给我发邮政编码之类的了。恭喜Paul获得T恤。真的很令人兴奋。太棒了。你想让我来提第一个问题吗？好的，开始吧。
So I know there are some in here that Jason is very ramped up about. But I'm going to pick a different one. I'm going to pick one that's maybe a bit more off topic to start with. And there are kind of two related here, I think. I'm going to try to capture them both. And that is, how do you deal with ergonomics and muscle pain, presumably related to programming? And do you use special ergonomic equipment or have certain stretches? And related, and that's from, oh, I'm not going to attempt to say people's usernames. That's from someone in
我知道这里面有一些Jason非常感兴趣的问题。但我打算选一个不同的。我先选一个稍微偏离主题的。我觉得这里有两个相关的问题，我试着把它们结合起来。那就是，你们如何处理人体工程学和肌肉疼痛，大概是与编程有关的？你们是否使用特殊的人体工程学设备或进行特定的拉伸运动？相关的问题是，来自，哦，我不打算尝试读出人们的用户名。这是来自某位在
the Discord channel. And then someone in the Discord channel. And then also in the Discord channel, someone was asking, which I think is somewhat related, how to effectively increase typing speed. So I'll take that away first. You know, I underestimated how nice it is to just have a really good adjustable office chair. And I will say that, like, I definitely had a lot of back pain when I was using essentially crappy chairs. And so getting a chair that has like a lot of adjustability, and then taking time to really fidget it into how I want it to be was a big help. Also, like as cheesy as it sounds, doing exercise, you know, specifically, like ab exercises helped me get rid of a lot of
Discord频道的人。还有一位Discord频道的人。另外，Discord频道里还有人问了一个我觉得相关的问题，如何有效提高打字速度。那我先回答这个问题。你知道，我以前低估了拥有一把好的可调节办公椅的重要性。我得说，当我用那些烂椅子时，确实背痛得很厉害。所以买一把可调节性很强的椅子，并花时间把它调整到我想要的状态，真的很有帮助。还有，虽然听起来很老套，但锻炼，特别是腹部锻炼，帮我缓解了很多
back pain, which is the thing that was killing me the most about sitting in programming all day. And then for the like wrist and, you know, kind of like finger finger stuff related to kind of typing, I think being efficient about what you do, and that's a whole topic, and trying to limit sort of like keyboard to mouse movement is great. Also, I use a split keyboard, which helped me a lot, get it at an angle that worked a lot better for me. But I've never been great about doing stretches. I know that they recommend them in the courses I've had to take in various corporate environments, but I've never done those.
背痛，这是我整天坐着编程时最痛苦的事情。至于手腕和手指，与打字有关的问题，我认为提高效率很重要，这是一个很大的话题，尽量减少键盘到鼠标的移动是很好的。此外，我使用分体式键盘，这对我帮助很大，让我能以更舒适的角度打字。但我从来不擅长做拉伸运动。我知道我在各种企业环境中参加的课程里都推荐这些，但我从来没做过。
And I guess related to the kind of typing speed, I guess part of it is I'm actually not that fast of a typer. I think Jason's a lot faster typer than me, for instance, having observed him type before. But for me, it's about having a keyboard. The split one's really good for me. Making sure at one point I wasn't touch typing. I had to look because I was terrible. So making sure that i actually knew how to type and then just
关于打字速度，我想部分原因是我其实打字并不快。例如，我观察过Jason打字，他比我快得多。但对我来说，关键在于键盘。分体式键盘对我来说真的很好。我曾经有一段时间不会盲打，我不得不看键盘，因为我太差劲了。所以确保我真的知道怎么打字，然后只是
making sure i'm efficient making sure that like i know what it is i'm going to type often that's the limiting thing not my typing speed so um uh if if there is an effective way to increase typing speed i don't know it and I've managed to do okay. I think like you can you can kind of work around that limit to how fast you type. Yeah, totally. Yeah. I mean, I think Patrick touched on a lot of the points that I would touch as well. I think I actually stand I don't have my desk goes up and down. I'm actually sitting now I sit when I do the episodes, but it's really the only thing I stand almost all the time. And so I don't have a good chair. I have some Ikea chair that I've had forever, but it's mostly just sits under my desk
确保我效率高，确保我知道我要打什么，通常这才是限制因素，而不是我的打字速度。所以，呃，如果有什么提高打字速度的有效方法，我不知道，但我已经应付过来了。我觉得你可以绕过打字速度的限制。是的，完全同意。我的意思是，Patrick提到的很多点我也想提。其实我站着办公，我的桌子可以升降。我现在坐着录节目，但这是我唯一坐着的时候，我几乎一直站着。所以我没有好椅子。我有一把用了很久的宜家椅子，但它大部分时间都放在桌子底下，
and I'm just standing the whole time. I did have occasionally some back pain. And that was one thing that really surprised me was, you know, when I talked to a physical therapist, they said that actually you're kind of what Patrick said, you know, your core strength and your abdomen strength actually is causing you to overuse your back muscles. You know, like not having that core strength is causing you to overuse your back muscles. And so she suggested a bunch of core exercises like you can be on a pull-up bar and try and bring your legs up and all of these things. And that actually had a tremendous impact. And so it's one of these things that I would have never known on my own. I would have assumed if you have back pain, there's something wrong with your back. But actually the way that, that the solution that worked really well for me and, and yeah, I do try to, you know, do a variety of, of stretches and exercises maybe about once or twice a week. I also, I mean, this is a, this is pretty geeky, but I have a lot of fun with it. I have the Oculus VR, and I actually put on wrist weights and then play the VR games. It triggers that competitiveness. You don't want to get killed by the boss in a sword fighting game. But now you're wearing these two, three know, two, three pound weights on each
我一直站着。我偶尔也会背痛。有一件事让我很惊讶，当我咨询物理治疗师时，她说其实就像Patrick说的，你的核心力量和腹部力量不足导致你过度使用了背部肌肉。所以她建议做一系列核心锻炼，比如在引体向上杆上尝试抬腿之类的。这真的产生了巨大的影响。这是我以前自己绝对想不到的事情。我会以为背痛就是背部出了问题。但实际上，对我非常有效的解决方案是这些，而且我确实尝试每周做一两次各种拉伸和锻炼。另外，这听起来很极客，但我玩得很开心。我有Oculus VR，我戴着腕重玩VR游戏。这激发了竞争心。你不想在剑术游戏中被Boss杀死。但现在你手臂上戴着两三磅的重物，
arm. So it makes it really hard. And if you can get through the Oculus video games with the weights on, it actually builds a lot of core strength. That's probably the best thing I've found as far as something that I want to do as a routine almost every day and get some exercise. As far as ergonomics, I have a vertical mouse, which I really enjoy. I've never really had wrist pain, so I couldn't tell you how effective it is, but I actually do enjoy just the way that a vertical mouse feels. It'd be terrible for video games or something, but when you're working, you really don't need to be that swift with the mouse. The vertical mouse just seems to feel a lot better. I don't have a particularly fancy keyboard or anything like that, so I I'll either bring a vertical mouse or I'll ask them to buy one and try and get some kind of standing situation.
所以这真的很难。如果你能戴着重物通关Oculus游戏，它确实能锻炼出很强的核心力量。这可能是我发现的最好的日常锻炼方式。至于人体工程学，我有一个垂直鼠标，我很喜欢。我从来没有真正经历过手腕疼痛，所以我不知道它有多有效，但我确实喜欢垂直鼠标的手感。它玩游戏可能很糟糕，但工作时你不需要鼠标移动得那么快。垂直鼠标感觉好多了。我没有特别花哨的键盘之类的，所以我要么带一个垂直鼠标，要么要求公司买一个，并尝试弄个站立办公的配置。
And then what about typing speed? Do you think that's important? Do you have any tips for increasing your typing speed? got way better when I started playing those massively multiplayer text games. So it's like, you'd have to type like east to go east or I mean, some of them you've mapped to macros, but then you type like, you know, cast fireball and all this stuff. And they're actually like PVP. So it's like if you could, if you couldn't cast a fireball, then someone like killed you and took all your equipment. So my typing speed got way higher. But yeah, I think Patrick's totally right. You know, your typing speed probably doesn't matter that much. If you do want to improve it. I think there's, you know, a lot of these games, you know, a really good way to do that. At least for me, you know, I think,
那么打字速度呢？你觉得重要吗？有什么提高打字速度的建议吗？当我开始玩那些大型多人在线文字游戏时，我的打字速度变快了。你必须输入“向东走”之类的指令，或者有些指令你映射成了宏，但你还得输入“施放火球术”之类的。而且它们实际上是PVP的。所以如果你不能快速施放火球术，别人就会杀了你并抢走你的装备。所以我的打字速度提高了很多。但是的，我觉得Patrick说得完全对。你的打字速度可能没那么重要。如果你确实想提高，我觉得有很多这样的游戏，是一个很好的方法。至少对我来说，
you know, it brings it that kind of competitive spirit. But I wouldn't feel compelled to improve typing speed. You know, if your goal is to be a great engineer, you know, that is very, very loosely aligned with that. I mean, there's other things that you can do. And we've talked about a ton of them on previous shows that would be better for that. But if you do want to type faster, it's a good skill to have. I think a lot of these games are a good way to do it. Cool. So we'll jump to...
它带来了那种竞争精神。但我不会觉得有必要去提高打字速度。如果你的目标是成为一名伟大的工程师，这与打字速度的关系非常非常小。我的意思是，还有其他事情可以做，我们在之前的节目中谈论过很多，那些对提升能力更有帮助。但如果你确实想打字更快，这是一种很好的技能。我觉得很多游戏是实现这一目标的好方法。酷。那我们跳到……
I'm actually just... I'll go top to bottom here. What are your thoughts on GPT-3 taking over? There's actually a bunch of questions along the lines of, what do we think about GitHub Copilot, GPT-3, and some of these AI coding assistant tools? I have to admit, I haven't used any of them, so I'm only going off of watching videos of
我其实只是……我从上到下看。你们对GPT-3接管一切有什么看法？其实有很多关于我们如何看待GitHub Copilot、GPT-3以及这些AI编程辅助工具的问题。我必须承认，我还没用过它们，所以我只是看了别人的视频。
other folks. You know, I feel like if you're writing a lot of boilerplate code, then you're probably doing something wrong. So in other words, if you ask a mean if you ask chat if you ask a gpt3 to you know build a website for you it has no context of your code base so it's going to build you an entire website and uh it's not going to reuse anything um i think that's going to be really the Achilles heel here is, you know, I think a lot of these demos are done in a, like in a sandbox, where you say, you know, I'm starting your main.cc, right? And, you know, design, you know, systems like return radar energy, and I've seen some crazy videos. But then, yeah, the problem is, you have to put that in context of a much bigger system. And so you might ask Copilot to write something and it writes a ton of stuff, but then someone else could have done the whole thing in a function call because that's been implemented somewhere else. So, yeah, I would have to say I'm a little bit bearish on Copilot.
我觉得如果你在写大量的样板代码，那你可能做错了什么。换句话说，如果你让ChatGPT为你构建一个网站，它对你的代码库没有任何上下文，所以它会为你构建一个完整的网站，而且它不会重用任何东西。我认为这将是致命弱点。很多演示都是在沙盒中完成的，你说“我正在启动你的main.cc”，然后设计系统，我见过一些疯狂的视频。但问题是，你必须将其置于一个更大的系统上下文中。你可能会让Copilot写一些东西，它写了很多，但别人可能用一个函数调用就完成了，因为那个功能已经在别处实现了。所以，我不得不说，我对Copilot持悲观态度。
Of course, maybe that's my own bias is like uh not wanting to be put out of business or whatever but yeah i'm pretty bearish on it i mean i think there's other amazing uses and there's other questions about gpt that we'll talk about but i feel like writing code uh with gpt is maybe not the best use of it yeah Yeah, I guess on that aspect of it, I am not particularly keen. I do think, I would say more like the co-pilot sort of approach where let's just say it's like line suggestion
当然，也许这是我自己的偏见，不想失业之类的，但我确实对它持悲观态度。我的意思是，我认为它有其他惊人的用途，还有关于GPT的其他问题我们会讨论，但我觉得用GPT写代码可能不是它最好的用途。是的，在这一点上，我不太热衷。我确实认为，更像是Copilot那种方法，比如行建议，
and like a better auto suggest as the default thing. And we've had a episode about that as well. I think those things can work. I think you can add a lot of, I don't know if this sounds bad, I'm going to be blasted for not being a general AI person. But I mean, I think you can add a lot of heuristics to some of that and make sure you limit it
作为默认功能的更好的自动建议。我们也做过关于这个的节目。我认为这些东西可以工作。我认为你可以增加很多，我不知道这听起来是不是不好，我会被那些通用AI支持者抨击。但我的意思是，我认为你可以在其中加入很多启发式算法，并确保将其限制在
to really high quality suggestions that fit, like you're saying, Jason, the context, right? So what is your next line going to be? You know, it's sort of like people for the first time getting really well done brace matching. It's just, it's really useful. And I totally think there will be some hinting systems that we see in the short term that work really well. But these long term where like, I just give a high level description, and it just works. And I've never seen a lot of thought to, you know, these questions say, like, hey, do this really large code base, and then I want to make a change, you know, or I want to maintain it or change it to do this or that. And like, do they just rewrite everything? Like, are they able to go in and make insertions? Maybe I just not look deep enough. But I think like, that's a big challenge. Like, you write your code,
真正高质量的建议上，就像你说的，Jason，要符合上下文，对吧？下一行应该是什么？这就像人们第一次使用非常好的括号匹配功能一样。它真的很有用。我完全相信短期内我们会看到一些效果很好的提示系统。但长期来看，那种我给出一个高层描述，它就能直接运行的情况，我还没见过。这些问题说，比如“嘿，处理这个庞大的代码库，然后我想做一个修改，或者我想维护它”，它们是直接重写一切吗？它们能进去做插入修改吗？也许我看得不够深。但我认为这是一个巨大的挑战。你写代码，
you need to check it for correctness, but you also need to kind of know how it works. So you know how to fix it when it breaks. If you spend twice as long fixing that generated code as you would have writing it in the first place. It's not a super clear win to me. People are talking about in the chat, but I think that's something that I saw recently discussed and we were talking about it on my work team was like in a programming interview where you have a technical interview and they're asked a question. My joke was like your question's kind of bad if it can be completely solved in a correct manner by one of these bots right now at least uh and you can't tell that it wasn't done by the person
你需要检查它的正确性，但你也需要知道它是如何工作的。这样当它坏了的时候，你知道怎么修复。如果你花在修复生成代码上的时间比你自己写的时间还要多两倍，那对我来说不是一个明显的胜利。人们在聊天中讨论这个，但我最近看到过讨论，我们在工作团队中也谈论过，比如在编程面试中，如果有人被问到一个问题。我的笑话是，如果这个问题能被这些机器人完全正确地解决，至少目前是这样，而且你看不出不是那个人做的，
i feel like you're probably asking too much of a bog standard question and you need to ask something that has variation or exploration where the person needs to explain themselves i personally have zero concern about someone typing the words I said into one of these bots and then writing that code back and me thinking that they know what they're doing. Because that's like such a small part of how I do the interview, at least in mine. That's very much related to,
那你问的问题可能太标准了，你需要问一些有变化或探索性的问题，让对方解释自己的思路。我个人完全不担心有人把我说的话输入到这些机器人里，然后把代码写回来，让我以为他们知道自己在做什么。因为这在我的面试中只占很小的一部分。这更多是关于，
well, why did you choose that? Why not this other thing? Oh, you used a hash map there. Like, what is the, you know, like asymptotic runtime of that hash map? And then, of course, oh, it's constant. Well, is it? Like, what if you're, you know, here you're doing this insertion over and over and over again.
“你为什么选择那个？为什么不是别的东西？哦，你在那里用了哈希映射。那么那个哈希映射的渐进运行时间是多少？”然后当然，“哦，是常数。”“真的是吗？如果你在这里一遍又一遍地做插入操作，
Are you really going to get a constant runtime if you're inserting millions of things into the hash map? Is it not going to grow? These kind of questions, right? And people who are relying on the chatbots to do that is not going to be effective. Yep. Yep. Totally agree. Yeah. You brought up an interesting point. We interviewed somebody and I know the new name of the company. It's now called SNYK, SNYK, but I forgot the old name um but we interviewed a company that was doing something like this right they were uh ingesting all of github and then using it to find errors in
如果你往哈希映射里插入数百万个东西，你真的能得到常数运行时间吗？它不会增长吗？”这些问题，对吧？那些依赖聊天机器人来做这些的人是不会有效的。是的，完全同意。你提到了一个有趣的观点。我们面试过一家公司，我知道这家公司的新名字，现在叫SNYK，但我忘了旧名字了，但我们面试的那家公司正在做类似的事情，他们摄取了整个GitHub，然后用它来查找你代码中的错误，
your code and i think that's a great idea um i mean i think that has a ton of potential and so yeah to your point it's like these these kind like these kind of tools that operate at a lower level. Look for array out of bounds, look for not handling a return correctly, help you match braces. I think there's huge potential for things like that. I think it was called DeepCode, but I'm totally drawing a blank. But anyways, it's now called SNYK SNICK. So if you listened to the DeepCode episode and wondered what happened to that company, go check out SNICK.
我认为这是一个好主意。我的意思是，我认为这非常有潜力。所以，回到你的观点，这些在较低层面运行的工具，查找数组越界，查找未正确处理的返回值，帮助你匹配括号，我认为这些东西有巨大的潜力。我想它以前叫DeepCode，但我完全想不起来了。但无论如何，它现在叫SNYK。所以如果你听过DeepCode那期节目并想知道那家公司发生了什么，去看看SNYK吧。
And we'll jump into another winner. So we have Warren Y. Warren Y. So Warren Y wins a Rage Against the Machines T-shirt. I don't know if folks saw this, but we have two T-shirt designs designed by yours truly. I'm not going to claim to be as good a T-shirt designer as, I don't even know who designs t-shirts. Anyways, but I have the original programming throwdown design, and then I also created a Rage Against the Machines written with all of the fonts from the Fang companies. And we'll be giving away both, you know, some of those as well. So Warren Y gets a Rage Against the Machines shirt unless we get sued. It's not Bang anymore, though, because a lot of them changed names now, right?
我们再选一位获奖者。我们有Warren Y。Warren Y赢得了一件“Rage Against the Machines”T恤。我不知道大家有没有看到，我们有两款由本人亲自设计的T恤。我不敢自称是像样的T恤设计师，我甚至不知道谁设计T恤。总之，我有最初的Programming Throwdown设计，我还创作了一件“Rage Against the Machines”，上面写满了FANG公司的字体。我们也会送出一些这样的T恤。所以Warren Y会得到一件“Rage Against the Machines”T恤，除非我们被起诉。不过现在不是FANG了，因为很多公司改名了，对吧？
Oh my god, mind blown. Wait, only Facebook, right? Did the other ones change names? Google is no longer Google. It's Alphabet now. Oh man. So yeah, it would be Mana or something. Also, with Netflix's Netflix market cap crash,
天哪，太震惊了。等等，只有Facebook改名了吧？其他公司改名了吗？Google不再是Google了，现在是Alphabet。天哪。所以，是的，可能是Mana之类的。而且，随着Netflix市值的崩盘，
I'm not sure they belong in the FANG acronym anymore. Yeah, you're right. So, okay, if we had to redo FANG, it would be... No, we're not getting on this. No, we don't have to. It's not... No one takes us seriously on stock stuff. But I would say
我不确定他们还属于FANG这个缩写了。是的，你说得对。好吧，如果我们必须重做FANG，那会是……不，我们不讨论这个。不，我们不需要。没人会认真对待我们的股票建议。但我会说
these companies that are half a trillion market cap obviously stay. Actually, wait. Was Fang... Fang was Amazon, right? Or was it Apple? Apple and Amazon. There's two A's. F-A-A-N-G. What? I thought it was There's two A's. F-A-A-N-G. What?
这些市值五千亿的公司显然会留下。等等，FANG是Amazon，对吧？还是Apple？Apple和Amazon。有两个A。F-A-A-N-G。什么？我以为是……有两个A。F-A-A-N-G。什么？
I thought it was Fang, like Wolf Fang. I've always seen it as two A's. Okay. Okay. Well, so we have, we have Meta, we have Apple,
我以为是Fang，像狼牙（Wolf Fang）那样。我一直看到的是两个A。好吧。好吧。那么我们有Meta，我们有Apple，
we have Amazon, and then we have Alphabet. So we have Ma, like a, it's now like a goat. Are there other companies that are really big tech companies?
我们有Amazon，然后我们有Alphabet。所以我们有MAA，现在像一只山羊。还有其他非常大的科技公司吗？
Like they're half a trillion? This is a question for looking up on Alphabet's search website, Google. So yeah, I guess I'll have to change the shirt. For now, we'll have... Actually, the shirt is fine because the shirt doesn't say Fang or anything.
比如市值五千亿的？这是个可以在Alphabet的搜索网站Google上查询的问题。所以，是的，我想我得换掉那件T恤。目前，我们会有……其实那件T恤没问题，因为上面没写FANG之类的。
So you can tell people this is my Rage Against the Machine shirt where I have all the fonts from Ma. Well, dude, you have like perfectly picked it so that Tesla falls ever so slightly short, 476 billion. So it's only Amazon, Alphabet, Microsoft, and Apple. Wow, Tesla was $800 at the start of the year, weren't they? Yeah, something very high. Oh my God.
所以你可以告诉别人这是我的“Rage Against the Machine”T恤，上面有来自MAA的字体。伙计，你选得太完美了，Tesla刚好差一点点，4760亿。所以只有Amazon、Alphabet、Microsoft和Apple。哇，Tesla年初是800美元，对吧？是的，非常高。天哪。
I mean, that is wild. I mean, I guess I think Facebook meta fell further than Tesla though. Meta is only $318 billion now. What? Wait, really? Wait, so Meta is not even in it according to my last definition. Tencent and TSMC and NVIDIA
我的意思是，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，我觉得Facebook Meta跌得比Tesla还惨。Meta现在只有3180亿。什么？真的吗？等等，所以根据我最后的定义，Meta甚至不在里面了。Tencent、TSMC和NVIDIA
are all higher than Meta and Tesla. Oh, wow. Okay. So it's really just, when I look at the economy in the end of 2022, all I can say is, ah. okay there was one on here good oh yeah here it is this is from Ben he says I haven't heard a lot of discussion around performance testing what do we think about that where does it fit in the software development life cycle kinds of nasty problems can you find is it worth it and is this a skill that a software an average software a typical software engineer should have or defer to experts. Um, this is one of those, uh, right.
都比Meta和Tesla高。哦，哇。好吧。所以，当我审视2022年底的经济时，我只能说，啊。好吧，这里有一个好问题，哦，在这儿，这是Ben问的，他说我没听到太多关于性能测试的讨论，你们怎么看？它在软件开发生命周期中处于什么位置？能发现什么棘手的问题？值得吗？这是普通软件工程师应该具备的技能，还是应该交给专家？嗯，这是其中一个，呃，
Like cliche phrase for it, but, um, it's one of those things where everyone loves to just go early optimization is the root of all evil don't don't optimize your code. Uh, I think the like real world answer is it's more nuanced than that. And I think, to me, if you're going to perform optimization or you're going to try to write a vision code and you don't have some kind of performance testing in mind, I don't know. I want to make strong comments,
陈词滥调，但是，嗯，这是每个人都喜欢说“过早优化是万恶之源，不要优化你的代码”。嗯，我认为现实世界的答案比这更微妙。而且我认为，对我来说，如果你要进行性能优化，或者你打算编写高性能代码，而你没有考虑某种性能测试，我不知道。我想发表强硬的评论，
but I'll refrain from saying that it's not worth it. I'll say that you should generally have an idea on how you would measure performance if you're going to try to optimize something or improve something. And I will say that I, in my coding, try to strike a reasonable balance. If the optimization is going to be very, very difficult and involved and make the code hard to read, and I'm not sure it's going to work. And you're almost always better off not doing it. But that being said, if you are building something from the outset that you can tell is going to break, not at 10 million users, as an example, but at 100 users or 1000 users, that's kind of a problem, right?
但我会克制自己，不说它不值得。我会说，如果你打算优化或改进某样东西，你应该大致知道如何衡量性能。而且我会说，在我的编码中，我尽量保持合理的平衡。如果优化非常非常困难且复杂，导致代码难以阅读，而且我不确定它是否有效，那你通常最好不要做。但话虽如此，如果你从一开始就构建一个明知会崩溃的东西，不是在1000万用户时，而是在100用户或1000用户时，那就有问题了，对吧？
Like, if you have a reasonable expectation, you're going to get more than that. And so I've seen people build something that fell over well within the sort of first expected amount of work it would need to do. Then they rewrote it to barely pass that only for it to fail over again when you had a 50% increase in the throughput needs. And so I think you can get
比如，如果你有合理的预期，你会得到超过这个数量的用户。所以我见过人们构建的东西在预期的第一阶段工作量内就崩溃了。然后他们重写它，勉强通过，结果当吞吐量需求增加50%时，它又崩溃了。所以我认为你可能会
into this problem where you're in a loop of barely making it work for the load you have, barely improving, barely improving, and you end up just really trying to incrementally improve something that needs to be kind of thought again from the ground up. But on the other hand, I have also seen people take tons and tons of time to build a very beautiful, well-optimized system that never got finished or never saw the light of day because they just took too long or misjudged. So you got to have some balance in there. But I will say that I do think every, in my experience, every engineer at some point, software engineer needs to know how to approach timing and measuring the performance of some code,
陷入这种循环，为了满足当前的负载勉强维持，勉强改进，勉强改进，最后你只是在试图增量改进一个需要从头重新思考的东西。但另一方面，我也见过人们花费大量时间构建一个非常漂亮、优化良好的系统，结果从未完成或从未面世，因为他们花了太长时间或判断失误。所以你必须在其中找到平衡。但我确实认为，在我的经验中，每一位软件工程师在某个时候都需要知道如何处理计时和衡量代码性能，
what the kind of underlying system impacts are into the measures of those performance. And I've worked with people that went and did what they thought was performance measurement and came back and effectively all they were measuring was noise. There was the signal they were looking for. They weren't testing it in a way that was going to give them the answer they want. And I think it's something that you don't have to be understanding of all parts of the system and, you know, amazing. That's your one and only special skill.
了解潜在的系统影响对性能衡量指标的影响。我曾与一些人共事，他们自以为在进行性能测量，回来后发现他们测量的实际上全是噪音。他们寻找的信号根本不在那里。他们测试的方式无法给出他们想要的答案。我认为这不是你必须理解系统的所有部分，或者成为这方面的唯一专家。
There are people like that. But I do think everyone needs some minimum competency in being able to assess how their code runtime looks and the performance of it. Yeah, that makes a lot of sense. So Ben, I have experience with performance testing. Performance testing is a type of testing that is conducted to evaluate the performance of a system or application under a given workload. And then the rest of the chat.
确实有那样的人。但我确实认为每个人都需要具备最低限度的能力，能够评估他们的代码运行时间看起来如何，以及它的性能表现。是的，这很有道理。所以Ben，我有性能测试的经验。性能测试是一种在给定工作负载下评估系统或应用程序性能的测试类型。然后是聊天记录的其余部分。
And then the rest of the chat. So yeah, Patrick is definitely the key person. I don't have a lot of experience with this. I will tell you a really funny horror story, though. People assume when they come to Google that all the code they see is going to be amazing and everyone's going to know how to write in every language and all of that. Not true. I mean, it's just normal people, right? And so I was in the AI org, and we had to stand up a website for like a dashboard to show the results of the model.
然后是聊天记录的其余部分。所以是的，Patrick绝对是关键人物。我在这方面没有太多经验。不过，我可以告诉你一个非常有趣的恐怖故事。人们认为当他们来到Google时，他们看到的所有代码都会很棒，每个人都会用每种语言编写代码等等。事实并非如此。我的意思是，这只是普通人，对吧？所以我当时在AI部门，我们需要建立一个网站作为仪表板来显示模型的结果。
So people who are using our model would have something to look at to see if it's getting better or worse. And the dashboard took maybe like two minutes when you hit the refresh button. I mean, maybe like anywhere from 60 to 120 seconds for the dashboard to go from, you know, I type in a URL to I see the result. And, you know, we just figured it was, you know, we were just pulling a lot of data. Like when it pulled up, there was tons of data and tables and everything. And so natural thing was like, oh, there's all this HTML, and we have to go and fetch all this data. So finally, I said, okay, we had a fix-it week.
所以使用我们模型的人会有东西可以看，看看它是在变好还是变坏。当点击刷新按钮时，仪表板可能需要两分钟。我的意思是，从我输入URL到看到结果，可能需要60到120秒。而且，我们只是认为，你知道，我们只是在拉取大量数据。当它加载时，有大量的数据、表格等等。所以很自然的想法是，哦，有这么多HTML，我们必须去获取所有这些数据。所以最后，我说，好吧，我们有一个“修复周”。
For people who don't know what that is, that's a week where you pause all of your objectives, and you just focus on making the code better. And no one wanted to touch this experiment dashboard. People were doing things around it to make it draw things without having to touch the experiment dashboard. And I finally said, okay, I'm going to rewrite the experiment dashboard in a week or at least get as close as I can and then keep working on it. And so the way the experiment dashboard worked, there was a function call, which is like HTTP get, but it's this was all in, in, in I think, Java or something.
对于不知道那是什么的人，那是一周时间，你暂停所有目标，只专注于让代码变得更好。没人想碰这个实验仪表板。人们在它周围做各种事情来让它绘制东西，而不必触碰实验仪表板。最后我说，好吧，我会在一周内重写实验仪表板，或者至少尽可能接近完成，然后继续努力。实验仪表板的工作方式是，有一个函数调用，就像HTTP GET，但这都是在，我想是Java或类似语言中。
So there's this one function call that returned a bunch of HTML. And the way it did it was, it had a string object. And so it was like string s equals, you know, open bracket HTML. And the next line was like, s plus equals, you know, like heading, and the next line was x plus s plus equals table. And then like, you can imagine the very last line of this function was s plus equals, you know, close bracket HTML. And in Java, every time you do that plus equals, Java creates like another copy of the string, right? That's big enough to hold both of them. And so, yeah.
所以有一个函数调用返回了一堆HTML。它的做法是，它有一个字符串对象。所以就像“String s equals，左括号HTML”。下一行就像“s plus equals，标题”，下一行就像“x plus s plus equals 表格”。然后你可以想象这个函数的最后一行是“s plus equals，右括号HTML”。在Java中，每次你做那个“plus equals”时，Java都会创建另一个字符串副本，对吧？大到足以容纳它们两个。所以，是的。
So literally I just changed string to string buffer. That was it. And it went from taking 120 seconds to taking like 30 milliseconds or something. That's actually impressive. Yeah, you just have to add the word buffer. And then at the end, you have to like convert it back to a string. It's like, oh my God.
所以我真的只是把String改成了StringBuffer。就是这样。它从需要120秒变成了只需要30毫秒左右。这确实令人印象深刻。是的，你只需要加上“buffer”这个词。然后在最后，你必须把它转回字符串。这就像，天哪。
That's where GPT-3 could come in. Like it could look at that function maybe and say... And totally replace that that individual low bar though gpt3 looks at the function and then fires people oh dear i i heard we'll pivot to a crazy story i don't know if you can confirm or deny this but i heard from people at twitter that the original plan was to print out your code on paper and then Elon and other folks would look at the stack size of the paper and then use that as like one of the heuristics to decide like who stayed and who left. So you show up with, you know, a dictionary,
这就是GPT-3可以发挥作用的地方。它可能看看那个函数然后说……完全替换掉那个低水平的代码。不过GPT-3看着那个函数然后把人解雇了。哦，天哪。我听说，我们转到一个疯狂的故事，我不知道你能不能证实或否认，但我从Twitter的人那里听说，最初的计划是把你的代码打印在纸上，然后Elon和其他人会看纸张的堆叠高度，并以此作为决定谁留下谁离开的启发式方法之一。所以你带着一本字典，
you know, size stack of paper, and you get to stay. That's what I heard. Yeah, I guess my fussing at the team to stop directly importing the generated proto-buff auto-generated code and having it make it from the proto-definitions instead, I guess, would hurt my stack.
那种大小的纸堆，你就能留下。我听说的是这样。是的，我想我一直催促团队停止直接导入生成的proto-buff自动生成代码，而是从proto定义中生成它，这可能会损害我的纸堆高度。
I should have just left all the auto-generated code in. Yeah. Can you imagine? So, you know, you imagine this like line of people and this person is, you know, walking down the line and all of a sudden this one person has a six foot high stack of paper and it's like, yeah, I wasted, you know, six feet of paper. You're fired anyways. That's too much.
我应该把所有自动生成的代码都留着。是的。你能想象吗？所以，你知道，你想象这一排人，这个人沿着队伍走，突然这个人有一堆六英尺高的纸，然后就像，“是的，我浪费了六英尺的纸。无论如何你被解雇了。”那太夸张了。
It like overflowed, the int overflowed and now you're at negative. Oh my gosh. I mean, let me just say, you know know i feel like compelled to just put a disclaimer i mean it's terrible when what's happening at twitter and folks getting laid off and everything so i mean what but i feel like it's you know you have to be able to make fun of of everything so so uh um yeah so yeah i do feel for those folks about trying to trivialize it, but a good joke is a good joke. All right. So we have, let's see, going down the list here. Someone asked, what kind of disruption to Google and Stack Overflow will ChatGPT have
它溢出了，整数溢出了，现在你变成了负数。天哪。我的意思是，让我说，你知道，我觉得有必要加个免责声明，我的意思是，Twitter上发生的事情以及人们被解雇等等，这太糟糕了。所以，我的意思是，但我感觉，你知道，你必须能够拿一切开玩笑。所以，呃，嗯，是的，所以我确实为那些人感到难过，试图将其轻描淡写，但一个好的笑话就是一个好的笑话。好吧。所以我们有，让我们看看，顺着名单往下看。有人问，ChatGPT对搜索行业，对Google和Stack Overflow会有什么样的破坏？
to the search industry? That's an interesting question. Have you thought about that, Patrick? It has huge implications. Ooh, does it fall? Does this just mean like in general, I don't know when to say like spam, like people putting up wrong answers
这是一个有趣的问题。你考虑过吗，Patrick？它有巨大的影响。哦，它会倒下吗？这只是意味着，比如通常所说的垃圾信息，比如人们发布错误的答案，
or overwhelming creating like fake content pages. Is that what they're asking? Are they meaning like doing something better? Rather than giving you a website result in Google, they would on-demand generate it? Well, for example, let's say you go on Stack Overflow and you ask a question like, how do I sort a list in Python or something?
或者压倒性地创建虚假内容页面。他们问的是这个吗？他们是指做一些更好的事情吗？而不是在Google中给你一个网站结果，他们会按需生成它？嗯，例如，假设你去Stack Overflow问一个问题，比如“我如何在Python中对列表进行排序”之类的。
So someone who wants to stack overflow, you know, virtual points or whatever, we'll just put that in a chat GPT, you know, post the answer. And then, you know, if they're right more than they're wrong, they end up with like positive karma. And they could just basically have this infinite karma generator yeah i mean i think like anything this is just a general like bad review problem like what i guess my question there would be what do do we eventually need to share the economic costs of running chat gpt like it costs money to run it if everyone's just doing that and it's very expensive to run it becomes like not that much different than you know hire outsourcing people to do the same thing so it's this like not to make it about economics like what is the reason for someone to do that like can you change the economics such that it's there's like no reason
所以有人想要Stack Overflow的虚拟积分之类的，就会把它放进ChatGPT，发布答案。然后，如果他们对的时候比错的时候多，他们最终会得到正向的Karma。他们基本上可以拥有一个无限的Karma生成器。是的，我的意思是，我认为像任何事情一样，这只是一个普遍的“差评”问题。我的问题是，我们最终是否需要分担运行ChatGPT的经济成本？运行它需要钱，如果每个人都在这样做，而且运行成本非常昂贵，它就变得和雇佣外包人员做同样的事情没什么区别了。所以这就像，不是为了谈论经济学，而是某人这样做的原因是什么？你能改变经济状况，使得他们没有理由
for them to do that um it is unfortunate like to have the deluge of stuff people could just write bad answers today i've thought a ton about it i i feel like it will be challenging but i i feel like there will be solutions to it i feel like there will be ways of asking you to change something or i don't know some challenge response that you could do to some of that to kind of like weed out. But maybe they'll also, it'll be a cat and mouse game, I guess, but maybe it always has been. Yeah, I wonder, you know, talking about the economics of it, obviously training the model requires an extraordinary amount of money. I saw
这样做吗？嗯，这很不幸，有大量的东西。人们今天就可以写错误的答案。我思考了很多，我觉得这会很有挑战性，但我感觉会有解决方案。我觉得会有一些方法要求你改变某些东西，或者我不知道，一些挑战响应，你可以对其中一些东西做，以剔除它们。但也许它们也会，这会是一场猫鼠游戏，我想，但也许一直都是这样。是的，我想知道，谈到经济学，显然训练模型需要极其巨大的资金。我看到
the figure, I feel like I'm going to misquote it, but it was an absolutely extraordinary amount of money. But I actually don't know what it costs to serve the model. I'm not sure if it is that expensive. I really don't know. I know that OpenAI will give you a pretty generous number of queries for free, but who knows what they're paying for those i guess the other thing i said though like if if they're so good that they're close or indistinguishable like does that not also mean maybe the companies can turn to using them themselves like i was sort of saying like generating you answers you want on demand and then they capture that instead of allowing other people to do that and then they don't even Like I was sort of saying, like generating you answers you want on demand.
那个数字，我觉得我会引用错误，但那是一笔绝对巨大的资金。但我其实不知道服务这个模型需要多少钱。我不确定它是否那么昂贵。我真的不知道。我知道OpenAI会免费给你相当慷慨的查询次数，但谁知道他们为这些付出了什么。我想我说的另一件事是，如果它们好到接近或无法区分，那是不是也意味着公司可以转而自己使用它们？就像我刚才说的，按需为你生成答案，然后他们捕获这些，而不是允许其他人这样做，然后他们甚至不需要……就像我刚才说的，按需为你生成答案。
And then they capture that instead of allowing other people to do that. And then they don't even need that whole problem, right? Stack Overflow is only useful if there are people on the site answering questions. But if you have a system that can actually reasonably answer all those questions and you don't need those people, and then you don't have this like, it's not exactly the marketplace problem, but you don't need to bring question askers and question givers together. You can stand up a website that's like a better Stack Overflow because it answers your specific version of the question the first time, every time. Yeah, really good question. I mean, really good point. Yeah, you know, it's amazing. That's a phenomenal point.
然后他们会把这些内容据为己有，而不是让其他人去做。这样一来，他们甚至不需要面对整个问题，对吧？Stack Overflow 只有在有人在网站上回答问题时才有用。但如果你有一个系统，它实际上能合理地回答所有这些问题，你就不需要那些人了，也就不会有这种——这不完全是市场问题，但你不需要把提问者和回答者聚集在一起。你可以建立一个网站，它就像一个更好的 Stack Overflow，因为它第一次就能回答你特定版本的问题，而且每次都能做到。是的，真是个好问题。我是说，观点非常好。是的，你知道，这太神奇了。这是一个了不起的观点。
I imagine that there'll be almost like a Stack Overflow Visual Studio Code extension where if punch in like, how do I center a div? And then chat GPT tells you. And then if that answer doesn't make sense or is wrong or you just can't interpret it, then you go to Stack Overflow. So it kind of like eliminates the whole bottom layer of questions there. I actually, I had a riddle that i remember from grade school
我想象中，未来几乎会有一个像 Stack Overflow 的 Visual Studio Code 扩展，如果你输入“如何让 div 居中？”，ChatGPT 就会告诉你。如果那个答案没意义或者错了，或者你只是无法理解，那么你再去 Stack Overflow。所以它在某种程度上消除了那里最底层的那些问题。其实，我记得小学时有一个谜语。
and i asked chat gpt3 and it got it right um so so i'll ask you patrick here turing test is patrick better than gpt3 so solve this riddle when you put this in a bucket, the bucket gets lighter. It's not, is this word for like emptiness? When you put this in a hole? Yeah, that's right. All right, it's official. Chat GPT-3, not as smart as humans. Hashtag solved.
我问了 ChatGPT-3，它答对了。嗯，所以我来问问你，帕特里克，图灵测试：帕特里克比 GPT-3 更聪明吗？来解这个谜语：当你把这个东西放进桶里时，桶会变轻。这不是，这个词是指“空”吗？当你把它放进洞里时？是的，没错。好了，官方结论：ChatGPT-3，不如人类聪明。标签：已解决。
Same humanity. This is not an AlphaGo scenario yet. I'm so glad. Oh man, I'm so glad. Oh, man. I'm surprised, ChadGPT, that you got that right. It's like literally, you know, it says the answer to the riddle is a hole and then it explains
还是人类赢了。这还不是 AlphaGo 那种情况。我太高兴了。天哪，我太高兴了。天哪。我很惊讶，ChatGPT，你竟然答对了。它字面上，你知道，它说谜语的答案是一个洞，然后它解释了……
a whole bunch of stuff about putting holes in buckets. It'll be interesting, you know, a lot of maybe bad has come out of the internet, but the amount of like machine learning input to be able to get to this point by basically just feeding it everything that's on the internet is crazy to me. Yeah, exactly. One second here. There we go.
一大堆关于在桶上钻洞的事情。这很有趣，你知道，互联网可能带来了很多坏处，但为了达到这一点，通过基本上把互联网上的一切都喂给它，所投入的机器学习数据量让我感到疯狂。是的，完全正确。等一下。好了。
Cool. So, yeah, let's see. We have a lot more questions about chat GPT3 or chat GPT that we could opine on. Actually, so, you know, maybe I'll just kind of briefly explain what chat GPT is for the audience, because this is something that I think I know pretty well. So, so GPT-3 is a forward model. So the idea is, you know, you can go on this Discord, and there's a whole bunch of folks writing sentences. And you can train a model that says given the sentence you know the fragment of the sentence up until now so maybe take the first five words the first seven words
酷。所以，是的，让我们看看。我们还有很多关于 ChatGPT-3 或 ChatGPT 的问题可以发表意见。其实，你知道，也许我会为听众简要解释一下什么是 ChatGPT，因为我觉得我对这个了解得还挺透彻的。所以，GPT-3 是一个前向模型。所以思路是，你知道，你可以去这个 Discord，有一大群人在写句子。你可以训练一个模型，它说给定这个句子，你知道，到目前为止的句子片段，所以也许取前五个词、前七个词……
of the sentence you know predict the eighth word or maybe say you know given the first five words predict the next five words right sometimes it's it's, you know, almost impossible, you know, because it's like, you know, I went to the book, you could have gone to anything, but many times it actually is very possible, right? As many cases where, you know, you almost know what the next word's going to be before the person says it. And so, you know, it generates a probabilistic model that kind of guesses the next word. So that's GPT-3. And given enough data and the right kinds of data, a lot of curation, all that, you can do this.
你知道，预测第八个词，或者也许说，你知道，给定前五个词，预测接下来的五个词，对吧？有时它是，你知道，几乎不可能，你知道，因为它就像，你知道，“我去了那本书”，你本来可以去任何地方，但很多时候它实际上是非常可能的，对吧？有很多情况，你知道，在人说出来之前，你几乎就知道下一个词会是什么。所以，你知道，它生成了一个概率模型，用来猜测下一个词。这就是 GPT-3。只要有足够的数据和正确类型的数据，加上大量的整理，所有这些，你就能做到。
And so then you could just say, well, here's like a prompt, or here's the start of a sentence, just keep generating the next word, and then use that as the input again to generate the next word, and then use that as the input, again, to generate the next word, and then do this again and again. What chat GPT does, the chat part is where what they did is they had GPT-3 generate several paragraphs for the same query. And then they had humans go in and pick the best one, or even just rank all of them. And so now you have a supervised signal. You have a person saying,
所以你就可以说，好吧，这是一个提示，或者这是一个句子的开头，继续生成下一个词，然后再次将其作为输入来生成下一个词，然后再将其作为输入，再次生成下一个词，然后一遍又一遍地这样做。ChatGPT 所做的是，聊天部分是他们所做的，他们让 GPT-3 为同一个查询生成几个段落。然后他们让人类进去挑选最好的一个，甚至只是对它们进行排名。所以现在你有了监督信号。你有一个人说……
okay, here's two sentences. Here's two paragraphs. This one's better than that one. And so you could do what's called contrastive learning. It was also called learning to rank back in the day, but now it's called contrastive learning. And so using contrastive learning, you can fine tune GPT to produce things that would be ranked higher according to people. That's the chat part. And yeah, that adding that piece is really been extraordinary. You can tell there's a perceptible difference between the two. I think it's yeah, like that fundamental way of trying to generate the negative. I guess it's really interesting. How much of the problem is finding the framework or the framing of how to sort of like set up things so that they work that way?
“好吧，这是两个句子。这是两个段落。这个比那个好。”所以你可以做所谓的对比学习。过去也叫学习排序，但现在叫对比学习。所以使用对比学习，你可以微调 GPT，使其产生根据人们评价排名更高的内容。这就是聊天部分。是的，增加那一部分确实非常了不起。你可以看出两者之间有明显的区别。我觉得，是的，那种试图生成负面内容的根本方式。我想这真的很有趣。找到框架或构建方式，即如何设置事物以便它们以那种方式工作，这个问题占了多大比例？
And how much of it is just like sizing or technology in the sort of like machine learning training itself? Yeah, it's a good question. I mean, I think that the techniques here are not that advanced. I think the hard part of GPT and chat GPT, there's several pillars here. One is it's really difficult to do this at scale, right? The scale, the cost, and all the complexity of that, and being able to iterate. I mean, GPT-3 is not literally the third iteration of GPT.
而机器学习训练本身的大小或技术又占了多大比例？是的，这是个好问题。我的意思是，我认为这里的技术并没有那么先进。我认为 GPT 和 ChatGPT 的难点在于，这里有几个支柱。一个是很难大规模地做到这一点，对吧？规模、成本以及所有这些复杂性，还有能够进行迭代。我的意思是，GPT-3 并不是字面意义上的 GPT 的第三次迭代。
I mean, they've done thousands and thousands of tests, right? And so being able to do that at scale is hard. The data curation is really hard. I mean, I think that's the secret sauce. I think a lot of people take for granted, they think that, I'll just download Wikipedia. And if I had enough time and energy and electrons, I could just train it. But I think they did an extraordinary amount of curation. I think there's all sorts of linguistic curation going on before the training starts. And then now you have all of the human labeling
我的意思是，他们已经进行了成千上万次测试，对吧？所以能够大规模地做到这一点很难。数据整理非常难。我的意思是，我认为那是秘诀。我认为很多人认为这是理所当然的，他们认为，“我只要下载维基百科就行了。如果我有足够的时间、精力和电子，我就能训练它。”但我认为他们做了非常大量的整理。我认为在训练开始之前，有各种各样的语言整理工作在进行。然后现在你有了所有的人类标注……
that they've done to do that last step that I referred to. That's also extremely expensive so um um so yeah i think that that that's actually where all the complexity is here i mean there's other things like alpha go where it's complex in different ways but here actually the algorithm i think is relatively straightforward and what do you think about the like you see it headlined everywhere like jailbreak or which i didn't understand what they were saying at first. Like I did, I had to kind of like look and like, oh, okay, I know what they're saying. Like basically people putting in guardrails or safeguards, like, oh, if we're doing image generation, we don't want real humans or we don't want nudity or we don't want people talking about racist themes. And so trying to put in what amounts to like, the model itself knows how to do those things. And so you need to kind of tell it not to at the end.
他们为了完成我提到的最后一步所做的工作。那也非常昂贵，所以……嗯……所以是的，我认为这实际上就是所有复杂性的所在。我的意思是，还有像 AlphaGo 这样的东西，它在不同方面很复杂，但在这里，实际上算法我认为相对简单。你觉得像到处都是标题的“越狱”之类的东西怎么样？我起初不明白他们在说什么。就像我，我不得不去查一下，然后，“哦，好吧，我知道他们在说什么了。”就像基本上人们设置护栏或保障措施，比如，“哦，如果我们进行图像生成，我们不想要真实的人类，或者我们不想要裸露，或者我们不想要人们谈论种族主义主题。”所以试图放入相当于，模型本身知道如何做那些事情。所以你需要在最后某种程度上告诉它不要这样做。
Like, what are your thoughts about that? Like, is that just a losing battle for them to kind of approach it that way? Yeah, it's a good question. So the thing about chat GPT is they, you know, they have that really powerful supervised layer at the top. And one thing that's really important is the top layer, the layer that's closest to the output, has a massively outsized impact. So, for example, look at MKL, which is...
你对那个有什么看法？就像，他们以那种方式处理它，这只是一场注定失败的战斗吗？是的，这是个好问题。所以关于 ChatGPT 的事情是，他们，你知道，他们在顶部有那个非常强大的监督层。有一点非常重要，顶层，即最接近输出的那一层，有着巨大的超额影响。所以，例如，看看 MKL，它是……
Oh, I forgot what it stands for. I think it's a multi-kernel layer. But anyways, it's basically MKL is where you have a deep network, right? You have some neural network, but the very end, the last layer, you use what's called a Gaussian process, gaussian process which is a very computationally expensive uh process um um so you couldn't you couldn't do it in the whole network but you just do it at the end and that by itself is really powerful it's able to affect because it's back propagation right doing something at the end you're able to back propagate your signal all the way to to back. So, um, so yeah, I mean, if you look at chat GBT by putting the supervised signal at the end, chat GBT ends up being very, very good at,
哦，我忘了它代表什么了。我想是多核层（Multi-Kernel Layer）。但无论如何，基本上 MKL 是你有一个深度网络的地方，对吧？你有一些神经网络，但在最后，最后一层，你使用所谓的“高斯过程”，高斯过程，这是一种计算成本非常高的过程……嗯……所以你不能在整个网络中这样做，但你只在最后这样做，而这本身就非常强大。它能够影响，因为它是反向传播，对吧？在最后做某事，你能够将你的信号一直反向传播到后面。所以，嗯，所以是的，我的意思是，如果你看看 ChatGPT，通过在最后放置监督信号，ChatGPT 最终变得非常、非常擅长……
um, sort of like dodging questions that it doesn't want to answer saying certain things are, are, are, um, you know, um, like not okay to talk about and kind of like always trying to like steer the conversation in certain directions it has almost like an uncannily human like politician political politician like ability to be able to do that now that's all the supervision um and yeah i think what they showed is that, I mean, you can actually, I've seen, you know, Twitter posts and stuff of list of prompts and then paragraphs to talk about and then rated it. So, for example, someone might say, the person who's building ChatGBG3 might have a prompt that says some like racially insensitive question. And then there's the three generated answers. And then they manually put in a fourth generated answer, like that they write by hand that says, you know,
嗯，某种程度上像躲避它不想回答的问题，说某些事情是，是，是，嗯，你知道，嗯，比如不适合谈论，并且总是试图引导对话朝着某些方向发展。它现在几乎有一种不可思议的、像人类政客一样的能力来做到这一点。现在，这全是监督的结果。而且是的，我认为他们展示的是，我的意思是，你实际上可以，我见过，你知道，推特帖子之类的，列出提示，然后是段落，然后进行评分。所以，例如，有人可能会说，构建 ChatGPT 的人可能有一个提示，说一些像种族歧视的问题。然后有三个生成的答案。然后他们手动输入第四个生成的答案，就像他们亲手写的那样，说，你知道……
I don't want to talk about this. It's offensive. And then they assign that one, like a huge positive score and like give a huge negative score to the others. Right. That's basically what's going on here. And that works, but that's going to have some amount of coverage. There's going to be, you're not going to be able to conceive of every single way of presenting, you know, that content. And so, you know, yeah, people always, you know, find a way to sort of like punch through that, I think. And so actually I asked ChatGPT3 to announce our next winner. And so we'll see what he said.
“我不想谈论这个。这很冒犯。”然后他们给那个答案分配一个巨大的正分，给其他的分配一个巨大的负分。对。这基本上就是这里发生的事情。这很有效，但这会有一定的覆盖范围。你不可能构思出呈现那种内容的每一种方式。所以，你知道，是的，人们总是，你知道，找到一种方法来突破那个，我想。所以实际上我问了 ChatGPT-3 来宣布我们的下一位获胜者。所以我们来看看他说了什么。
So Christian B had been wanting to add a new T-shirt to his collection for weeks. I was excited when he saw the programming throwdown one at the mall. At the mall. Okay, well, let's not get ahead of ourselves. Christian B. stopped by the store to see if it was in stock and was pleasantly surprised when the salesperson offered him the chance to win a shirt by answering a trivia question about surfing. Christian B. confidently answered that the question was Kelly Slater and was thrilled when he was correct.
所以 Christian B 几周来一直想在他的收藏中增加一件新 T 恤。当他在商场看到 Programming Throwdown 的那件时，他很兴奋。在商场。好吧，我们别操之过急。Christian B 顺便去了商店看看是否有货，当售货员给他机会通过回答一个关于冲浪的琐事问题来赢得一件衬衫时，他感到惊喜。Christian B 自信地回答说那个问题是 Kelly Slater，当他答对时，他非常激动。
He left the store feeling grateful and proud to add the T-shirt to his collection. So, Christian B., you got a T-shirt and a story from ChadGBT3. Congratulations. Oh, dude. be you got a t-shirt and a story from chat gpt3 congratulations oh dude i sense a i sense a new future for all of these things where yes we get wordplay from our overlords kelly slater is uh that was uh what was that saved by the bell right yes oh man i just we just dated ourselves all right i got a couple of questions that i think a little bit related here so first one from a collection of letters as a username is it better to refer to documentation for a beginner or follow a video guided course And then for a young wannabe programmer, what should be the key focus points or checkpoint?
他离开商店时感到感激和自豪，将这件 T 恤加入到了他的收藏中。所以，Christian B，你从 ChatGPT-3 那里得到了一件 T 恤和一个故事。恭喜。哦，伙计。你从 ChatGPT-3 那里得到了一件 T 恤和一个故事，恭喜。哦，伙计，我感觉到，我感觉到所有这些东西的一个新未来，是的，我们从我们的霸主那里得到了文字游戏。Kelly Slater 是，呃，那是，呃，那是《Saved by the Bell》，对吧？是的，哦，伙计，我们刚刚暴露了我们的年龄。好吧，我有几个我认为在这里有点相关的问题。所以第一个来自一串字母作为用户名，对于初学者来说，参考文档更好，还是跟随视频指导课程更好？然后对于一个年轻的准程序员，关键的关注点或检查点应该是什么？
I think this is a great question. I generally don't tell people to start with reading the documentation. I guess it depends if you are looking for a specific answer to something or if you're trying to learn how to do a new thing. So just making up an example, if you want to learn how to use Unity or Unreal Engine and you go straight to the actual technical documents, probably not going to help you if you're not already
我觉得这是一个很好的问题。我通常不告诉人们从阅读文档开始。我想这取决于你是想寻找某个特定问题的答案，还是想学习如何做一件新事情。所以随便举个例子，如果你想学习如何使用 Unity 或 Unreal Engine，而你直接去看实际的技术文档，如果你还不是……
a video game programmer. Maybe it'll help some people. I'm not saying it can't be done. Just probably a bit difficult. Whether that you go to a video course, or just a general tutorial, those are probably going to be be more helpful. That being said, the more niche you get into a topic, if you're in some specific, you know, shared pointer issue and deep in the depths of C++ with templates and something,
一个视频游戏程序员，那可能帮不了你。也许它会对某些人有帮助。我不是说这做不到。只是可能有点困难。无论你是去看视频课程，还是只看一个通用的教程，那些可能更有帮助。话虽如此，你对一个主题研究得越深入，如果你陷入了某个特定的，你知道，共享指针问题，深入到 C++ 模板的深处，还有别的东西……
probably going to be difficult to find a whole video guided course or even a tutorial on it. You're probably going to get something much more akin to technical documentation or maybe a question on Stack Overflow, something like that. So there you're definitely going to have to be. For someone learning to program, the key focus points I feel like are driven from an interest. I think if you can try to do something that keeps you engaged and interested, I don't think it's Malcolm Gladwell was exactly right with whatever it was, 10,000 hours to become an expert at something. But I do think you just need time doing programming and programming adjacent things for it to click. And so whatever can keep you motivated, I feel is going to be better than trying to hit some specific.
可能很难找到一个完整的视频指导课程，甚至连教程都很难找到。你可能会得到更类似于技术文档的东西，或者可能是 Stack Overflow 上的一个问题，诸如此类。所以在那方面你肯定必须得……对于学习编程的人来说，我觉得关键的关注点是由兴趣驱动的。我认为如果你能尝试做一些让你保持参与和感兴趣的事情，我不认为马尔科姆·格拉德威尔（Malcolm Gladwell）说的那个什么 10,000 小时成为某方面专家的说法完全正确。但我确实认为你只需要时间去做编程和与编程相关的事情，它才会产生共鸣。所以任何能让你保持动力的事情，我觉得都比试图达到某个特定的……
And I think that can be what makes it difficult that there's not you just do A, then B, then C, then D, and then you're a programmer. I think finding a way for you to try simple problems to make progress, but always be working. I do think, I guess, trying to finish things or at least get enough progress on things and so that you're doing iterations and doing pieces of the arc, the software development lifecycle, however you want to call it, that you're doing it and getting repetitions on it. I think that is useful. So sitting down and saying, I want to build, you know, Dwarf Fortress, and I'm going to just start from scratch. That's pretty difficult because it's gonna be a long time before you kind of circle back
而且我认为这可能就是困难所在，没有那种你只要做 A，然后做 B，然后做 C，然后做 D，然后你就是程序员了。我认为找到一种方法让你尝试简单的问题来取得进展，但要一直工作。我确实认为，我想，尝试完成事情，或者至少在事情上取得足够的进展，这样你就在进行迭代，并完成软件开发生命周期的各个部分，无论你想怎么称呼它，你在做它并进行重复练习。我认为这很有用。所以坐下来，说，“我想构建，你知道，矮人要塞（Dwarf Fortress），我要从零开始。”这相当困难，因为在你绕回来之前会花很长时间……
in a meaningful way having completed it. But yeah, I think mostly trying to align it to your sort of like interest and desire will keep you motivated and keep you spending time in the subject yep yep yep totally agree um yeah i think i think yeah that's a really good point i mean i think you should always have something kind of cool that you want to build because that that's also a sign to you that you're kind of entering the right discipline right if you like if you kind of follow a bunch of tutorials then you know you might build some skills but if you go at it from first principles and say i want you know to not have to compute my tips by myself i want my app to do it um then then uh um you know if you kind of exercising you know the right muscles to turn that into something real and then getting that feeling at the end that that's gonna kind of
以一种有意义的方式完成它。但是是的，我认为主要是尝试将其与你的某种兴趣和愿望保持一致，会让你保持动力并让你在主题上花费时间。是的，是的，是的，完全同意。嗯，是的，我想，我想是的，这是一个非常好的观点。我的意思是，我认为你应该总是拥有一些你想要构建的酷东西，因为那也是一个信号，告诉你你正在进入正确的学科，对吧？如果你，如果你跟随一堆教程，那么，你知道，你可能会建立一些技能，但如果你从第一性原理出发，说“我想要，你知道，不必自己计算小费，我想要我的应用程序来做它”，那么，那么，嗯，你知道，如果你在锻炼，你知道，正确的肌肉来把那个变成真实的东西，然后最后得到那种感觉，那会……
tell you a lot more about your connection to the discipline cool so yeah i have an email question that i'll that we'll get to but first let's announce another winner since we're running a little bit low on time um so i hopefully i can say this right so the first name is z e h and the last name starts with an f so z i'm assuming that's z um you won a rage against the machine t-shirt and uh i asked uh chPT3, it said, Zed, a skilled hacker, learned about a contest offering a free t-shirt to anyone who could successfully hack into a clothing company's website and retrieve a hidden message. After several hours, Zed found a way in and located the message, sending it back to the company as proof of his hack. The company thanked him and offered him the free t-shirt as promised, which Zay eagerly accepted and wore with pride. Congratulations, Zay, on your t-shirt.
告诉你更多关于你与这门学科的联系。酷，所以是的，我有一个电子邮件问题，我们稍后会处理，但首先让我们宣布另一位获胜者，因为我们的时间有点紧。所以，希望我能读对这个名字，第一个名字是 Z E H，姓氏以 F 开头。所以 Z，我假设那是 Z，你赢了一件“暴力反抗机器”（Rage Against the Machine）T 恤。而且，呃，我问了 ChatGPT-3，它说：“Zed，一名熟练的黑客，得知一场比赛，向任何能成功入侵服装公司网站并检索到隐藏信息的人提供免费 T 恤。几个小时后，Zed 找到了进入的方法并定位了信息，将其发回给公司作为他黑客攻击的证明。公司感谢他并按承诺提供了免费 T 恤，Zay 欣然接受并自豪地穿上了它。”恭喜 Zay 获得你的 T 恤。
I look forward to the future when people get their little narrative stories on the t-shirt that they win. Oh, man. Okay, next year, we got it. That's actually a great idea you know connect chat gpt to like cafe press or something i mean we get a lot of christmas cards i guess maybe this is an old person thing but like you get a lot of christmas cards from people you've met over the years from family whatever and they always include a little story i think i'm just to get chat GPT to write my story next year. Just like, I have these kids. They generally were good.
我很期待未来人们在他们赢得的 T 恤上得到他们的小叙事故事。哦，伙计。好吧，明年，我们搞定了。这实际上是个好主意，你知道，把 ChatGPT 连接到像 Cafe Press 之类的东西上。我的意思是，我们收到很多圣诞贺卡，我想也许这是老年人的事情，但就像你从多年来认识的人、家人、无论什么人那里收到很多圣诞贺卡，他们总是包含一个小故事。我想我明年就让 ChatGPT 写我的故事。就像，我有这些孩子。他们通常表现很好。
They were in school. And I have a wife. Like, make a letter. That'd be amazing if they could lay out the photos and everything, too. Oh. That'll just generate the photos. They don't need to be real. That doesn't have to be our family. I mean, who cares?
他们在上学。我有一个妻子。就像，写一封信。如果他们能把照片和所有东西也排版好，那就太棒了。哦。那只会生成照片。它们不需要是真的。那不必是我们的家庭。我的意思是，谁在乎呢？
Related to the previous question, this one was good. And then maybe we could do another email one. Coding books that were great, but time proved them wrong. That's an awesome question. I tried really hard to think about one here in the last few minutes. I didn't come up with any. There have to be some pretty funny ones from 20 years ago, 30 years ago, right? Like, oh, we have to be careful because computers only have kilobytes
关于上一个问题，这个很好。然后也许我们可以再做一个电子邮件问题。很棒但被时间证明是错误的编程书籍。那是一个很棒的问题。我在过去几分钟里非常努力地想一个。我没想出来。20 年前、30 年前肯定有一些非常有趣的，对吧？比如，“哦，我们必须小心，因为计算机只有几千字节……”
of memory and something, right? Just all the classic misunderstanding the exponential growth. And then on the flip side, I bet more recently, you probably find some giving you guidance sort of like, yeah, don't worry, the computer will always get faster. That turns out not to be true. That would be like an easy one. I'm trying to think of there are probably like dead methodologies as well, or like dead programming languages or languages that didn't really go anywhere that people thought were going to be really hot for a while. Anything Google does. I think like think you could just probably find books about those things that are no longer useful. But Jason, you have any books
的内存之类的，对吧？只是所有经典的误解指数增长。然后另一方面，我敢打赌最近，你可能会发现一些给你指导的书，比如，“是的，别担心，计算机总是会变得更快。”事实证明那不是真的。那会是一个简单的例子。我在想，可能还有像死掉的方法论，或者像死掉的编程语言，或者人们认为会火一阵子但实际上没去向何处的语言。任何谷歌做的东西。我想，我想你可能就能找到关于那些不再有用的东西的书。但是 Jason，你有没有读过什么书……
you read and you're just like, this is just bad advice? Yeah, I mean, I'll have to check. I keep all of the notes on the books I read in this website that I built the front end using Dart and the back end is using Golang. And actually, Golang is popular. But yeah, I would say, OK, there's two angles to this. One is there's been several AI winters, right? So folks have promised the whole world and then turns out, oh, AI is actually not that easy. So that's definitely there, but yeah, as far as technology, I think that, uh, um, I mean, there's definitely a whole bunch of defunct, uh, or, or just like libraries that are just, uh, languishing, right. I mean, dart comes to mind, but there's a ton of
然后你只是觉得，“这简直是糟糕的建议？”是的，我的意思是，我得查一下。我把我读过的书的所有笔记都保存在这个网站上，我用 Dart 构建了前端，后端用的是 Golang。而且实际上，Golang 很流行。但是的，我会说，OK，这有两个角度。一个是已经有几次人工智能寒冬了，对吧？所以人们承诺了整个世界，然后结果发现，哦，人工智能实际上并没有那么容易。所以这绝对存在，但是的，就技术而言，我认为，呃，嗯，我的意思是，绝对有一大堆倒闭的，呃，或者，或者只是像正在凋零的库，对吧。我的意思是，Dart 浮现在脑海中，但还有很多……
others. So yeah, there's, I wouldn't, I don't know if it's a thing about books or books, especially books about programming are usually not very opinionated. It starts to get really opinionated when you talk about AI or the singularity or these other things. But yeah, I mean, I would say there's probably been just like huge volumes about how to, how to code in Dart or how to write in some language that never really took off. I remember reading day trading books when I was younger. I don't want to say that this was before the dot-com crash,
其他的。所以是的，有，我不知道这是否是关于书的事情，或者书，特别是关于编程的书通常不是很有主见。当你谈论人工智能或奇点或这些其他事情时，它开始变得非常有主见。但是的，我的意思是，我会说可能已经有大量的书关于如何，如何用 Dart 编码，或者如何用某种从未真正流行起来的语言编写。我记得我年轻时读过日内交易的书。我不想说这是在互联网泡沫破裂之前……
when everyone was sort of day trading. I remember going to the library and seeing books about day trading, whatever, that just a few short years later would have turned out to make you like absolutely bankrupt. You know, do you remember, like, you know, when you have these market crashes or, you know, in the hype phase, like at peak hype, there's always those people who are day trading and telling you how amazing they're doing and everything. You know, maybe that's like, there's got to be someone who's looked into this and said, oh, and when everyone starts telling you how easy it is to day trade, that's a sign that's all going
当每个人都在某种程度上进行日内交易时。我记得去图书馆看到关于日内交易的书，无论什么，仅仅几年后就会让你变得绝对破产。你知道，你还记得，像，你知道，当你有这些市场崩盘时，或者，你知道，在炒作阶段，就像在炒作高峰期，总是有那些人在进行日内交易，告诉你他们做得多么棒，一切都很好。你知道，也许那是，一定有人研究过这个并说，哦，当每个人开始告诉你日内交易有多容易时，那就是一切都要……
to fall apart. We had this calculus professor in high school who was literally day trading. He would give a lecture and then he would give us some worksheets and then he would day trade and uh on the computer in the classroom and that was what 1998 97 or something so then like yeah the economy fell apart a year later i thought you were going to go crypto on that one people who talk about crypto all the time and then just disappear um i have a interesting kind of meta thing here i asked chat gbt3 to write a story about a coder and i'm not going to say the name yet because i'll spoil it but who gets a free t-shirt by dividing by zero and and chat gpt3 like uh chat gpt literally can't do it like i'm getting all sorts of weird errors and everything like maybe putting divide by zero
分崩离析的信号。我们高中有一位微积分教授，他简直是在进行日内交易。他会讲课，然后给我们发一些工作表，然后他会在教室里的电脑上进行日内交易，那是 1998 年还是 97 年左右。所以然后，是的，经济一年后就崩溃了。我以为你要在那上面谈论加密货币。那些整天谈论加密货币然后就消失的人……我这里有一个有趣的元问题，我问 ChatGPT-3 写一个关于程序员的故事，我还不打算说名字，因为我会剧透它，但谁通过除以零得到了一件免费 T 恤，而 ChatGPT-3 就像，呃，ChatGPT 简直做不到，就像我得到了各种奇怪的错误和一切，就像也许把除以零……
in the question is causing gpt to have a heart attack like it's just having a really hard time it It's just seg faulting. Oh dear. Yeah, I asked chat GPT to tell me when it halted and OpenAI just went out of business. Just ask it the halting problem and then just somewhere there's a fire. Oh yeah, one thing that really confuses it that I get a huge kick out of is when you talk past the sale
放在问题里导致 GPT 心脏病发作，就像它只是遇到了很大的困难，它只是在段错误（seg faulting）。哦，亲爱的。是的，我让 ChatGPT 告诉我它什么时候停止，OpenAI 就倒闭了。只要问它停机问题，然后就在某处着火了。哦，是的，有一件事真的让它困惑，我从中得到了巨大的乐趣，那就是当你谈论超过销售额时……
you know so when you say something like explain why the halting problem can be solved if you use haskell so it's like you've presupposed something that's totally bogus and it tries its best i mean it's uh it's so so but but yeah it generates some absolutely hilarious things oh it won't point out that you're like you're giving it something contradictory right right i mean sometimes it does but the majority of time when you talk past the sale it will just try its best to make that a reality oh here we go i got it okay it's up but the fourth attempt it actually tells you how many attempts um i don't know why i had to take four for this but um james k james k our next winner was a skilled coder who loved nothing more than solving complex problems one day while deep in thought
你知道，所以当你像这样说，“解释为什么如果使用 Haskell，停机问题就可以解决。”所以就像你预设了一些完全虚假的东西，它尽力而为。我的意思是，它是，呃，所以，所以，但，但是的，它生成了一些绝对滑稽的东西。哦，它不会指出你像，你给了它一些矛盾的东西，对吧？对，我的意思是，有时它会，但大多数时候当你谈论超过销售额时，它只会尽力让那成为现实。哦，开始了，我得到了。好的，它上去了，但第四次尝试它实际上告诉你尝试了多少次。嗯，我不知道为什么我不得不尝试四次，但……James K，James K，我们的下一位获胜者是一位熟练的程序员，他最喜欢解决复杂的问题。有一天，在沉思时……
james had an idea he remembered reading about a strange phenomena known as a division by zero error. If he could trigger this error, he might be able to find a way to win a t-shirt. Excited by this, he typed out one line of code that would trigger the error. To surprise, the code worked perfectly, and he was able to get a solution to the divide by zero problem. As a reward for his hard work, the company he worked for offered him a free t-shirt. James accepted the prize with a smile. The end. It actually said the end.
James 有个主意。他记得读过一种被称为“除以零错误”的奇怪现象。如果他能触发这个错误，他也许能找到赢得 T 恤的方法。对此感到兴奋，他打出了一行代码来触发这个错误。令他惊讶的是，代码运行得非常完美，他能够得到除以零问题的解决方案。作为他辛勤工作的奖励，他工作的公司给了他一件免费 T 恤。James 微笑着接受了奖品。完。它实际上说了“完”。
We need to generate stories about two handsome podcast hosts becoming enormously wealthy and out of their generosity giving out because they gave out free t-shirts. There we go. Oh, that's a great idea. Write a story about two people who gave out free t-shirts and somehow tripped and fell into a wad of cash. Oh, man. Yeah. Oh, yeah.
我们需要生成关于两位英俊的播客主持人变得非常富有，并出于慷慨大方而赠送，因为他们赠送了免费 T 恤的故事。好了。哦，那是个好主意。写一个关于两个人赠送免费 T 恤，并以某种方式绊倒掉进一堆现金里的故事。哦，伙计。是的。哦，是的。
Let me get to the email question. I definitely want to cover that. We have a couple here, but let's do the first one. Machine learning is, I'm going to summarize here, and this is from Jeremy S. Machine learning is a really interesting topic to me. I want to jump into that field, but I'm not sure where to start. Yeah, I get this question all the time um so you know sorry if this sounds like i can't answer but i've thought a lot about this and and so my take on this is is the following um at the end of the day like if you are working on software you know you're building some type
让我来处理电子邮件问题。我一定要涵盖那个。我们这里有几个，但让我们做第一个。机器学习是，我在这里总结一下，这是来自 Jeremy S 的。机器学习对我来说是一个非常有趣的话题。我想跳进那个领域，但我不知道从哪里开始。是的，我一直被问到这个问题。嗯，所以你知道，抱歉如果这听起来像我无法回答，但我已经深入思考过这个问题，所以我的看法是以下几点……归根结底，如果你在从事软件工作，你知道，你正在为某个受众构建某种类型的……
of software product for some audience right and so and so when you build it you try and use common sense, you say well I would want it to do this or I want the compiler to tell me quickly when there's an error or I want the map when I open the maps app to start at my location, so that's all common sense but sometimes you get it right and sometimes you don't to start at my location. So that's all common sense. But sometimes you get it right and sometimes you don't. And the only way you really know if you are thinking on the same level as your audience is to collect data, collect metrics, and try different things and see how that affects
软件产品，对吧？所以，所以当你构建它时，你尝试使用常识，你说，“好吧，我希望它做这个，或者我希望编译器在有错误时快速告诉我，或者我希望当我打开地图应用程序时，地图从我的位置开始。”所以这些都是常识，但有时你做对了，有时你做错了，从我的位置开始。所以这些都是常识。但有时你做对了，有时你做错了。而你真正知道你是否在与你的受众处于同一水平思考的唯一方法是收集数据、收集指标，并尝试不同的事情，看看这如何影响……
the metrics, right? And so you can't actually, you know, if you work for, like, you can't actually build the best product unless you're measuring things and then reacting to those measurements, whether it's a game or an app or a website or anything. Even a compiler, they need to ask, you know, their audience, you know audience questions and learn more about their use cases. And so you can't build software without running headfirst into this problem. And you can't solve it without some amount of statistics and machine learning, right? I mean, even if it's as simple as I'm going to, you know, group of my bug reports and work on the one with the most, the topic with the most reports. So that's still some way of looking at metrics and then reacting to them. And so you could argue,
指标，对吧？所以你实际上不能，你知道，如果你为，像，你实际上不能构建最好的产品，除非你在衡量事物，然后对这些衡量结果做出反应，无论是游戏、应用程序、网站还是任何东西。即使是编译器，他们也需要问，你知道，他们的受众，你知道，受众问题并更多地了解他们的用例。所以你不能在不一头撞进这个问题的情况下构建软件。而且你不能在没有一定数量的统计学和机器学习的情况下解决它，对吧？我的意思是，即使简单到“我要，你知道，对我的错误报告进行分组，并处理报告最多的那个，主题最多的那个。”所以那仍然是查看指标然后对它们做出反应的一种方式。所以你可以争辩……
well, how did I do that grouping? Did I do it by hand? Can I automate that? And so this is a really good place for people to start. So if you're a software engineer, you want to get into machine learning, a really good conduit is to find the team that's collecting metrics and learning about the product and just embed yourself in that team. And you invariably hit like all of the most interesting problems in machine learning. You're not going to hit, you know, the things like computer graphics and stuff, but all the interesting problems related to sort of decision theory and all that you'll hit with almost any software product.
“好吧，我是怎么做那个分组的？我是手工做的吗？我可以自动化吗？”所以这对人们来说是一个非常好的起点。所以如果你是一名软件工程师，你想进入机器学习，一个非常好的渠道是找到正在收集指标并了解产品的团队，然后把自己嵌入到那个团队中。你总是会遇到机器学习中所有最有趣的问题。你不会遇到，你知道，像计算机图形学之类的东西，但所有与某种决策理论相关的有趣问题，你几乎会在任何软件产品中遇到。
That seems pretty reasonable. Yeah, I don't have any specific advice on that. But yeah, I mean, I think, yeah, it makes a lot of sense. Yeah. Sorry, I lost my place here. Patrick, do you have any questions you want to cover? Are there any from the chat? I think we got most of them from the chat.
这看起来相当合理。是的，我对此没有任何具体的建议。但是的，我的意思是，我想，是的，这很有道理。是的。抱歉，我在这里迷路了。Patrick，你有什么想涵盖的问题吗？聊天里有什么吗？我想我们已经涵盖了聊天里的大部分问题。
I didn't curate the list of the email ones, but I'm looking here. People are wanting a hangout, Jason. They want a way to meet. I think we can virtual one easy and person one. I guess it depends on where. Let's see. Looking for any
我没有整理电子邮件的问题列表，但我在这里看。人们想要一个聚会，Jason。他们想要一种见面的方式。我想我们可以轻松地进行虚拟聚会和面对面聚会。我想这取决于在哪里。让我们看看。寻找任何……
others. I think we got a lot of these covered. Yeah. I'm terrible at email. I apologize if i lost your question just uh either uh post in the chat and the questions channel on discord and we'll make it up to you but uh yeah for some reason i thought i had a second one actually it's gone somewhere else but uh um but yeah this was awesome i mean we covered a lot of good content let me do let's do the final uh sixth t-shirt so um what should we have this person do patrick to get their t-shirt uh is this the last one this is the last one? This is the last one. Have them give an amazing outro to a podcast.
其他的。我想我们已经涵盖了很多这些。是的。我不擅长电子邮件。如果我漏掉了你的问题，我很抱歉，只要，呃，在 Discord 的聊天和问题频道里发帖，我们会补偿你的。但，呃，是的，出于某种原因，我以为我有第二个问题，实际上它去别的地方了，但，呃，但是的，这太棒了，我的意思是，我们涵盖了很多好的内容。让我做，让我们做最后的，第六件 T 恤。所以，呃，我们应该让这个人做什么，Patrick，来得到他们的 T 恤？这是最后一个吗？这是最后一个。这是最后一个。让他们给播客做一个精彩的结尾。
Oh, that is a great idea. We're going to make it very unhappy. There we go. All right, well, ChatGVT is kind of thinking about that. Maybe we should do some predictions. Oh, actually, so last year, if I remember correctly, I wonder if we have it in our notes. But last year, I remember one prediction that you made that really stood out was that you felt like space was going to be kind of like a big motif for the year. And I think you kind of got that right um you know i think that like i
哦，那是个好主意。我们要让它非常不开心。好了。好吧，好吧，ChatGPT 正在考虑那个。也许我们应该做一些预测。哦，其实，所以去年，如果我没记错的话，我不知道我们笔记里有没有。但去年，我记得你做的一个预测非常突出，那就是你觉得太空会成为这一年的一个大主题。而且我想你某种程度上做对了，嗯，你知道，我想，像我……
personally got really into spacex and and all that i mean i got in you know really into the hype there yeah there have been like a crazy number of launches this year like i mean i think i was hoping starship but they have some regulatory. There have been a crazy number of launches. The Spin Launch team had a pretty cool test. A number of other projects have marched forward. I think it's one of those pretty awesome things that continues to move. I don't think we're there yet. Look at the Starlink became kind of a big thing this year, right?
个人对 SpaceX 和所有这些非常感兴趣，我的意思是，我，你知道，真的对那里的炒作非常感兴趣。是的，今年有疯狂数量的发射，就像，我的意思是，我想我当时希望是星舰（Starship），但他们有一些监管问题。有疯狂数量的发射。Spin Launch 团队进行了一次非常酷的测试。许多其他项目也向前推进了。我认为这是继续前进的那些非常棒的事情之一。我不认为我们还没到那一步。看看 Starlink 今年成为了一件大事，对吧？
And we saw a bit with stuff that happened in Ukraine. And people started to see that this is a pretty transformative thing. And this is like already up and running. This is like not a one time going to be there. It's there now. Yeah, totally. I mean, one thing I said, I know, I'm cherry picking things that that had the most consequence or were most correct on so you know i totally understand but but one thing that i talked about a lot last year for predictions for next year was uh that education was going to just like radically change and um i actually predicted that they would privatize scholarships i mean i was you know for for and I don't know if my prediction was a year or not, but, but, but looking at what happened there, I mean, a number of things did happen along those lines. So one, you know, college enrollment has completely tanked. So,
我们看到了一点在乌克兰发生的事情。人们开始看到这是一个相当具有变革性的事情。而且这已经启动并运行了。这就像不是一次性会到那里。它现在就在那里。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我所说的一件事，我知道，我在挑选那些影响最大或最正确的，所以你知道，我完全理解，但，但有一件事我去年为明年的预测谈了很多，那就是教育将发生彻底的改变，而且，嗯，我实际上预测他们会私有化奖学金。我的意思是，我当时是，你知道，为了，而且我不知道我的预测是否是一年，但，但，但看看那里发生了什么，我的意思是，确实发生了一些事情。所以第一，你知道，大学入学率完全暴跌。所以……
so, so people are just not going to college at the same rate. So that's a seismic event. There was a whole effort around student loan forgiveness that I think it fell through at some point, but it was in the zeitgeist for a while. Oh, that's right. Yeah, the court disputed it. Yeah. But it was in the zeitgeist for a while. And it does seem like, I do think that my prediction is going to come true eventually that that you know there's going to be some type of privatization of higher education like to a much greater degree it's gonna be like a seismic shift towards privatization um so yeah i think we're marching towards something there are you gonna make new ones i think i'm gonna be boring and just stick with like space being like a huge thing this next year. But maybe you have some more interesting take.
所以，所以人们只是没有以同样的速度上大学。所以那是一个地震事件。围绕学生贷款减免有整个努力，我认为它在某个时候失败了，但它在时代精神中存在了一段时间。哦，那是对的。是的，法院对此有争议。是的。但它在时代精神中存在了一段时间。而且确实看起来，我确实认为我的预测最终会成真，即，你知道，会有某种高等教育的私有化，程度要大得多。这将像是一场向私有化的地震式转变。所以是的，我认为我们正在朝着某个方向前进。你要做新的预测吗？我想我会很无聊，只是坚持像太空成为明年的一件大事。但也许你有更有趣的看法。
Yeah, I think that I think that the same predictions are just continuing to play out. Oh, okay. I do think that I mean, this is not anything mind blowing, but I do think there'll be some type of economic collapse in 2023. I mean, everyone's kind of saying that. But what's your take on that? I mean, do you go with the flow on that? Or do you think it's people are being too bearish? I mean, look, everyone's saying, oh, they knew, they knew. People at work are saying they knew. I mean, to be fair, people have been saying there would be something like that
是的，我想，我想同样的预测只是继续上演。哦，好的。我确实认为，我的意思是，这不是什么令人震惊的事情，但我确实认为 2023 年会有某种经济崩溃。我的意思是，每个人都在那样说。但你对此有什么看法？我的意思是，你随波逐流吗？还是你认为人们太看空了？我的意思是，看，每个人都在说，哦，他们知道，他们知道。工作的人都在说他们知道。我的意思是，公平地说，人们一直在说会有类似的事情……
or this or however long. I heard some discussion with, I don't know the name now of the person, but it was an economist. And they were saying what they think, and I was a good take on it. If you look at times that were most similar to now with this steady margin inflation, Fed raising the rate in the United States, stuff we see around the globe. This has kind of happened to us before.
或者这个，或者无论多久。我听到一些讨论，我不记得那个人的名字了，但那是一位经济学家。他们正在说他们的想法，我觉得这是一个很好的看法。如果你看看与现在最相似的时期，有这种稳定的边际通胀，美联储在美国加息，我们在全球各地看到的东西。这以前发生在我们身上过。
And it turns out it's just really boring. You just end up with a really slow slide down and then a really slow recovery that we're used to in the last 30 years, like bubbles and pops and crashes and then V-shaped recoveries or things at least happening one side or the other very, very quickly. But I think their take was like, this is something that will probably play out over like a decade. So when you have like a U-shaped thing that has like, it does have a minima, but you don't feel it so strongly when it's U-shaped
结果发现这真的很无聊。你最终只会经历一个非常缓慢的下滑，然后是我们在过去30年里习惯的那种非常缓慢的复苏，比如泡沫、破裂、崩盘，然后是V型复苏，或者至少是某一方面非常迅速地发生变化。但我认为他们的观点是，这可能需要十年左右的时间才能显现出来。所以当你遇到像U型这样的情况时，它确实有一个最低点，但当它是U型时，你不会有那么强烈的感觉
and not V-shaped, right? And so this may play out over the next, you know, sliding down the next two, three, four years, you'll start to get mixed things. Some things will start to stabilize, some things will get worse. Then you'll start to see a few things getting better, less things getting worse, more things stable. And then eventually things will tip back up and we'll be in a recovery. But you won't be able to know it, you won't know it till later. And I feel like that's probably a reasonable guess about what's going to happen. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, thinking back to 2008, 2008, there was definitely like a crash that spanned over months, right? I mean, I'm trying to struggling to maybe even less than that and then you're right the recovery really took maybe what four or five years or so i do remember there was a period maybe it's like 2010 or 2011 where i just felt like
而不是V型，对吧？所以这种情况可能会在接下来的两、三、四年里缓慢下滑，你会开始看到各种混合的情况。有些事情会开始稳定，有些事情会变得更糟。然后你会开始看到一些事情好转，变糟的事情减少，更多的事情趋于稳定。最终情况会好转，我们将进入复苏阶段。但你无法察觉，直到事后你才会知道。我觉得这大概是对未来将会发生什么的合理猜测。是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，回想2008年，2008年确实发生了一场持续数月的崩盘，对吧？我的意思是，我甚至觉得可能持续的时间更短，然后你是对的，复苏确实花了大概四五年左右的时间，我确实记得有一段时间，可能是2010年或2011年，我当时感觉
the economy has been bad for so long it's like you almost i started to forget what it was like to have a good economy. All right. So we asked Zhu. Zhu is our last winner. Congratulations. It's X-U. So I'm sorry if I'm butchering that, but I believe it's Zhu. Zhu L is our last winner. And we asked him to, we asked ChatGVT to write an outro of the podcast. So here we go. Zhu is a big fan of the podcast Programming Throwdown,
经济已经糟糕了太久，以至于我几乎快要忘记经济好转是什么样子了。好了。我们问了Zhu。Zhu是我们最后一位获胜者。恭喜。名字拼写是X-U。如果我读错了请见谅，但我相信是Zhu。Zhu L是我们最后一位获胜者。我们让他，我们让ChatGPT写了一段播客的结尾。所以我们开始吧。Zhu是Programming Throwdown播客的忠实粉丝，
and he loved listening to the latest episodes when they were released. One day while listening to the latest episode, Zhu had an idea for an outro that he thought would leave a lasting impression on the listeners. And here's Zhu's outro. Thank you for tuning... Yeah. I'm literally reading this on the fly, so help us here.
他喜欢在最新一集发布时收听。有一天，在听最新一集时，Zhu想到了一个结尾，他认为这会给听众留下深刻的印象。这就是Zhu写的结尾。感谢收听……是的。我真的是在现场读这个，所以帮帮我们。
Thank you for tuning in to this episode of Programming Throwdown. We hope you enjoyed the discussion and found it helpful. If you have any comments or suggestions for future episodes, please don't hesitate to reach out to us. We always welcome feedback from our listeners. Thanks for listening. As a token of appreciation, the hosts offered you a free t-shirt with the show's logo on it, which is actually exactly what we're doing, so thank you so much. It was amazing, but it was so vanilla.
感谢收听本期Programming Throwdown。我们希望你喜欢这次讨论并从中受益。如果你对未来的节目有任何意见或建议，请随时联系我们。我们随时欢迎听众的反馈。感谢收听。作为感谢，主持人为你提供了一件印有节目Logo的免费T恤，这实际上正是我们正在做的，所以非常感谢。这太棒了，但它太普通了。
It was good, though. The only part of this we can't validate is that these folks are wearing them with pride. I notice every answer from ChatGBT3, every paragraph ends with the person wearing the shirt with pride. It's up to you. take photos of yourself wearing your programming third-hand t-shirts with pride and add us on Twitter. I guess actually, you know, just to sort of close the whole loop here is
不过这很好。我们无法验证的唯一部分是这些人是否自豪地穿着它们。我注意到ChatGPT3的每一个回答，每一段的结尾都是“自豪地穿着这件衬衫”。这取决于你。拍下你自己自豪地穿着Programming Throwdown T恤的照片，并在Twitter上添加我们。我想，实际上，为了结束整个话题，
I do think that these generative AI models are going to be a huge, huge part of the next three, four years. Because, I i mean just imagine all the different things that you're going to see disrupted like spam is going to look completely different next year i mean that's yeah that's the i don't know why i keep going to that such a negative example but just you know i mean i mean like all the like okay imagine if you were what's that company that has the images you know like if you need an image for a presentation, you could pay them five bucks.
我确实认为这些生成式AI模型将在未来三四年里占据非常非常重要的地位。因为，我的意思是，想象一下你将看到的各种被颠覆的事物，比如垃圾邮件明年看起来会完全不同，我的意思是，是的，我不知道为什么我一直举这么负面的例子，但你知道，我的意思是，比如，好吧，想象一下如果你是那家拥有图片的公司，你知道，如果你需要一张演示文稿的图片，你可以付给他们五美元。
Shutterstock, I think. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like Shutterstock is going to be, you know, they're under enormous pressure now, right? Because you could just generate a photo and who cares if the person, you know, doesn't look exactly right. So, yeah, I think it's going to be just extraordinary what's going to happen oh the other part of this is people are generating pictures and texts and it always starts with like very low level sensory things like pictures and
我想是Shutterstock。是的。是的。是的。就像Shutterstock现在将面临巨大的压力，对吧？因为你可以直接生成一张照片，谁在乎那个人看起来是否完全正确呢。所以，是的，我认为将会发生的事情将是极其非凡的。哦，这部分的另一面是人们正在生成图片和文本，它总是从非常低级的感官事物开始，比如图片和
texts but imagine if you could generate games or you could generate um like imagine if you could generate games or you could generate, like imagine if you could, if your goal is to train a, like a police officer to decide who is at fault in like a traffic jam. And so you could like generate like more and more like confusing traffic jams and like, you know, it could get harder and harder and you could train them. Or imagine if you could train them or imagine if you could generate the advertising so like instead of having to find the picture and the text for the
文本，但想象一下如果你能生成游戏，或者你可以生成，嗯，比如想象一下如果你能生成游戏，或者你可以生成，比如想象一下如果你能，如果你的目标是训练一名警察来决定谁在交通堵塞中负有责任。所以你可以生成越来越多令人困惑的交通堵塞，你知道，它可能会变得越来越难，你可以训练他们。或者想象一下如果你能训练他们，或者想象一下如果你能生成广告，这样你就不用去寻找图片和文本来制作
ad i mean i guess it's that's the same picture and text stuff but but i think the generative stuff will become sort of domain specific and uh that's where it can get extremely extremely interesting i i dread our future. It's going to be amazing. All right, everybody. Hey, this was a pleasure having so many folks here with us and, you know, folks in the chat and over email and supporting us on Patreon. Thank you so much for a year of that.
广告了。我的意思是，我想这还是同样的图片和文本内容，但我认为生成式内容将变得特定于领域，这就是它变得极其极其有趣的地方。我为我们的未来感到担忧。这将会很棒。好了，各位。嘿，很高兴有这么多朋友在这里和我们在一起，还有聊天室里的朋友，通过电子邮件联系我们的朋友，以及在Patreon上支持我们的朋友。非常感谢你们这一年的陪伴。
We really appreciate all of your time, your energy, your feedback, and your years. I appreciate having those for an hour or so every couple of weeks. So thank you so much. And I'm looking forward to an exciting 2023. We have another lineup of really exciting guests. Patrick and I are also going to do a few, you know, a bunch of duo episodes. So that's going to be a lot, you know, a bunch of duo episodes. So that's going to be a lot of fun. And we're looking forward to all of that. Music by Eric Barneller. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license.
我们非常感谢你们的时间、精力和反馈，以及你们的陪伴。我很感激每隔几周能有这样一个小时的时间。所以非常感谢。我期待着激动人心的2023年。我们还有另一系列非常令人兴奋的嘉宾。Patrick和我也会做一些，你知道，一系列的双人节目。所以那将会非常有趣。我们期待着这一切。音乐由Eric Barneller创作。Programming Throwdown根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议分发。
You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，进行改编，但你必须注明Patrick和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。